صباح الخير ، صباح الخير ، صباح الخير ،
أنت بخير ، هنا نذهب
هذا الصباح 634 أنت تعيش على صفحة كريس
كل أسبوع
1.3 مليون مستمع للاستيقاظ على
الراديو المخضرم دي جي كريس يتلاشى ما لديك من
أجلي ولكن عندما تتوقف الميكروفونات
ويظهر العرض الصباحي  تم الانتهاء منه ليوم آخر
يتلاشى التركيز ويتحول إلى شغفه الآخر ،
مصير شركتها الناشئة الجديدة التي
أطلقها الأطفال العام الماضي ، الشركة الناشئة هي
علامة تجارية للوجبات الخفيفة الصحية ، وبدأت الأعمال في
الانطلاق من خلال تقديم الحلويات بأسعار معقولة التي
تم بيعها بالفعل في أكثر من 400 منفذ في جميع
أنحاء الإمارات العربية المتحدة في هذه المرحلة المبكرة  يتعلق
نجاح حياة الشركات الناشئة
بإدارة الوقت مثلها مثل أي شيء آخر ، فهذه هي
المرة الأولى التي أفعل فيها
شيئًا كهذا حقًا كنت أعمل في الراديو
لغسل السيارات.
مع تقدمنا ، أدرك أنه يح
اج إلى مزيد من الاهتمام ولا أمانع في ذل
وبدأت الآن أحاول تح
يق التوازن بين كل ما لدي من حياة الراديو التي يع
شها الأبوة ، هل
حن مستعدون سأكون مستعدًا للذهاب إلى  العمل ،
حسنًا ، دعنا نذهب ، لقد ذهبنا إلى
المصنع ، تعال إلى
[الموسيقى]
للعديد من رواد الأعمال الطموحين ،
الحياة الأسرية هي أول شيء نعاني منه
والسعي وراء نجاح أعمالهم ، لكن
التلاشي وجدت حلاً فريدًا
أشرك أطفالي فيه لأنني كنت أرغب في تناول وجبات خفيفة
بالنسبة لهم ، كنت أرغب في منحهم
خيارًا صحيًا ، لذلك عندما بدأت
في إعداد وجبة خفيفة
، كانوا بمثابة اختبار الذوق ، وهكذا
بدأوا نوعًا ما في العمل
مباشرة من المدرسة إلى اجتماع العمل
في الشركة المصنعة ، يتلاشى ذلك لأن
البنات جاهزات للعمل.  أريد أن
أترك إرثًا لأولادي ، فأنا أريد
فتياتي إذا أردن تولي هذه
الشركة يومًا ما ، كونك شركة ناشئة ،
كونك رئيسك الخاص أمر
مهم للغاية وإذا كان بإمكاني تعليمهن في
هذه السن المبكرة الآن في  20 عامًا ،
أين سيكونون من يعرف شركة
عائلية بهدف الوصول إلى
العالمية وما هي إلا البداية
لهذه العلامة التجارية المحلية ، فهناك الكثير مما
يحدث لا يمكنني الكشف عن كل شيء ولكن ما
يمكنني قوله  هو أننا سنحصل على
مجموعة فيتامينات مناسبة للأطفال خالية من السكر ،
وسيكون هناك مذاقات ميسورة التكلفة
مذهلة كيف أعرف ذلك لأن أطفالي جربوها